okay so I'm gonna start out today's
lecture on the wrong foot by quoting
somebody that you guys probably don't
know and who was a New York Yankee so
Yogi Berra the famous I Yankee catcher
once said you can observe a lot by
watching okay and that is very
appropriate for biology because there's
a lot of a lot of things in biology have
been discovered simply by watching for
them in cells or watching for them to
happen at the molecular level and so our
ability to visualize and see what's
going on inside cells and at the
molecular level is really critical for
the process of biological discovery so
today I'm gonna tell you about tools
both sort of older tools but also kind
of the cutting edge for how biologists
are really observing what's going on in
living cells and in life in general
okay so let's let me start budgets
having you guys think a little bit what
what do you require of me to see what I
write on the board yeah Rachel what's
that you need light mm-hmm and what does
the light help you to do
what's that you need it to see the board
and so let's say the lights on okay is
that can you read this no what's the
problem what's that sighs right so
Natalie suggested sighs right so one
thing that you need is some amount of
magnification right but let's let's take
another let's say I do magnify this what
if I magnify it and I'm gonna start
writing my notes on the board right
how's this helpful what Jeremy what's
wrong yeah you have to be able to
distinguish different objects in this
case these letters right so in addition
to just magnifying it you also need the
structures to be far enough apart such
that you can distinguish them so you
need what is known as resolution okay
this was resolution but this is
resolution where the letters are
actually resolved okay so structures
need to be far enough apart so that you
can resolve them now let's come back to
Rachel's point right why is it that we
need light to see what's on the board
right if I
another what if I just what if I draw
without pressing right is that yeah
or II unique contrast exactly right the
light sort of gives you contrast between
the chalk and the black part of the
board so you also need contrast and
contrast is the ability to the
structures need to have they need to be
differentiated from the background
okay so structures need to be different
from background what else do you need to
read my writing
right what if what if I were just to
everyone you can read that what's wrong
Carlos what's that yeah I need to have
like good handwriting right so I like to
think of this as this is an aspect of
like sample preservation okay so there's
a sample preservation issue
I can't butcher the letters and the
words okay so in the process of doing
all these other things right magnifying
your image resolving things in your
image and generating contrast you can't
destroy your sample such that it's
illegible basically okay so in this case
structure must be preserved while doing
one through three on this list
okay so I'm gonna start with resolution
we'll talk about what are the limits to
resolving things and biological
specimens and in biology the one
instrument we use a lot is a microscope
okay and a microscope is basically a
collection of lenses that allow you to
do many of the things I just drew on the
board I'll point out a couple sort of
broad sort of types of microscopy so the
human eye appear can resolve up to about
100 to 200 microns if you're looking at
something at reading distance distance
right but cells are like way smaller
than that right so we need some sort of
instrument that allows us to see things
that is lower than the resolution limit
of a human eye and so one way is to use
a light microscope where you're using
visible light to observe your sample and
many of the images that you're seeing
that we're showing you are from visible
light microscopes to see smaller things
type of microscope that's often used is
an electron microscope an electron
microscopy allows us to observe
structures all the way down to the sub
nanometer level of resolution okay now
one limitation to the electron
microscope is you have to kill the
sample okay so that that can lead to
artifacts and problems and we'll discuss
a way at the end that where light
microscopy is being extended down to the
limits that approximate that of an
electron microscope okay so what
determines then the resolution of a
microscope and so I'm going to sort of
define a measurement of resolution which
I'll call the demon
or minimum distance and this will be the
minimum distance between two points that
can be resolved okay and what I showed
you on that past slide is basically the
the limit on the right here is the D min
for these different types of microscopy
techniques okay and what that means is
so the minimum distance would be if your
minimum distance is 200 nanometers if
two points are greater than 200
nanometers apart from each other then
you can distinguish them as two
different objects however if they are
closer than 200 nanometers together you
wouldn't be able to see that these are
two different objects they would be
overlapping each other okay
and typically the D min for a light
microscope is around 200 nanometers okay
and the D min results if we were to
determine what if I'm to tell you what
what determines this minimum distance we
have to think about a microscope so here
I'm drawing a specimen here I've just
drawn my specimen it's on a slide or a
coverslip here's your specimen here and
you might have a light source to
generate the contrast
and then there'd be some sort of
objective lens underneath the slide and
the specimen so this would be an
objective lens sorry about my sample
preservation here and so the light is
going to be hitting the sample and the
objective lens will be collecting a cone
of light that's going into the lens here
okay and I'll maybe I'll I'll magnify
this a bit so you can see it better so
I'm just gonna magnify this region over
here so if this is my specimen I'm gonna
draw the objective a little farther away
this time this is the objective and the
objective is able to capture a range of
different angles of light that come from
the specimen okay so it's collecting
angles and I'll just define here an
angle theta which is like the half angle
of this whole cone of let of light okay
so what determines the resolution limit
in this type of system is first of all
the wavelength of the light that's used
so your your if you're using white light
that might be from 400 to 800 if you're
exciting GFP you're going to excite with
a wavelength that's 488 nanometers so
it's usually around maybe between 450
and 550 nanometers for many different
fluorescent proteins
okay so lambda here is the wavelength of
the excitation or though of the light
you're using
and this is all then divided by two
times the NA which is a property of this
objective and what na is an a stands for
numerical aperture and what what that is
is it's basically the range of angles
that this objective can collect okay so
it's n sine theta where theta l-- theta
is this angle here so you get the best
performance if the objective can collect
all of the light that comes from this
side of the sample okay and then n
refers to the refractive index of the
media that this light is going through
okay and so if you have an objective and
you have your sent your sample and here
and it's honest there's a slide in a
coverslip I'll extend this out you often
have emergen
there'd be some sort of immersion media
here and I don't know if you've ever
used a mic microscope this meant to be
used with immersion media and you don't
add that immersion media but your image
quality if you don't add that media is
like really bad right and that's because
that's because you're affecting the
numerical aperture of sort of what this
lens can correct collect and therefore
you degrade your image quality okay but
basically the more light the more angles
of light that you collect the higher the
numerical aperture and therefore the
lower this demon is going to be and
the greater you'll be able to resolve
objects that are that are near each
other in space okay so the take-home
message from all of this is that you
notice that magnification is not a part
of this but the wavelength of the light
is really critical okay so usually this
minimum distance ends up being the
wavelength of light that you're using
divided by two and this usually ends up
being about 200 nanometers so that's the
diffraction limit of a light microscope
as you see up there and this resolution
limited is this this resolution is
basically limited by the diffraction or
behavior of light okay so light
microscopy is limited by the diffraction
of light
and it was thought for a long time that
no matter what you do you'd never be
able to break this limit of about 200
nanometers but at the end of the lecture
I'll tell you about some very smart
people who figured out a way to actually
break this limit and we'll talk about
how they were able to do that now I want
to talk about a few other limitations of
of microscopy and I'm starting by
showing you this electron micrograph of
the endoplasmic reticulum and one
important consideration you have to make
is two dimensional versus three
dimensional structure so for an electron
microscopy you basically cut the sample
so you have a very thin slice of it just
like slicing bread okay except these
slices are on the order of 30 to 60
nanometers in height and then you pass
an electron beam through the sample
after it stained in order to visualize
your specimen and one thing you have to
keep in mind is that you're just you're
looking at a slice through this and it
doesn't give you three-dimensional
information okay so if we were to think
about the endoplasmic reticulum right
you might have a endoplasmic reticulum
and if you take an optical slice through
this then you would see something like
this where you see each of the stacks
individually
and so this might make you to conclude
that the way the endoplasmic reticulum
is structured is it's kind of like a
stack of pancakes where each of these is
you have a lipid bilayer surrounding a
lumen of the ER so right the lumen would
be inside like this for each of these
and they're just stacked on top of each
other and this is the textbook model for
endoplasmic reticulum structure but it
was actually I think the if if you don't
consider this in 3d you might miss
something and what was missed was
reported in 2013 in this paper where
rather than just taking a single slice
what they did is they they made lots of
slices and they kept track of where they
are so they basically did a
three-dimensional reconstruction of the
endoplasmic reticulum and by imaging
this other dimension they came to a very
different conclusion about how the
endoplasmic reticulum is organized and
instead of being it stacks of membres
membranes on top of each other like
pancakes instead it's a helicoid so this
is a proffesional ER from a professional
secretory cell like a salivary gland
cell and you can see in 3d you get a
very different picture of the
organization of this organelle it's
actually wrapped around and spiraling
membranes stacks okay so their model is
that basically the endoplasmic reticulum
and some cell types is basically has a
parking garage like structure okay so in
this case in these cells it seems like
the the ER is basically a parking garage
for ribosomes okay and you don't get
that information unless you consider the
three-dimensional structure of the the
thing that you're looking at so in
addition to electron microscopy there
are techniques that involve light
microscopy that involve optical
sectioning
and so normally if you're looking at a
fluorescence if you're doing
fluorescence microscopy you'd be
exciting the whole volume of your sample
and exciting all the fluorophores such
that fluorescence from out of the focal
plane would be getting into your image
and that would give you a much more hazy
unclear image but there are techniques
such as confocal fluorescence microscopy
that allow you to exclude the
out-of-focus light such that you're
basically getting an optical section
through your sample and that can give
you a much cleaner and better resolved
image okay now I want to talk a little
bit about another dimension which is
time and again you're you're you're
seeing images and textbooks and usually
you're just seeing a single image and
you whenever you see a single image you
have to think about how things might be
changing in time in order to understand
the system so one example that I like
here is shown here where these are
different proteins that are labeled in a
yeast cell and you see that these
proteins form patches at the edge of the
yeast cell and some of these patches
just contain the green protein which is
SL a1 and other patches contain just the
red protein which is a B p1 and there's
another class a patch which contains
both okay so how might you interpret
this this fixed image over here what
might be one model you would conclude
well what was what was initially
concluded from this type of experiment
is you have three different types of
patches that are that are distinct from
each other in the cell because they have
different molecular compositions okay
and that was what was initially thought
but it was wrong because researchers had
to really consider the aspect of time in
this problem and I'm gonna show you a
movie now over here where you see this
yeast cell and now you have these
different proteins tagged with different
fluorescent proteins and we can watch
them in in time as they progress through
a stereotypic cycle so what you're going
to notice in this movie is that you see
these green patches appear and every
single green patch at some point is
joined by red and then the green
disappears and the red stays around and
then the thing disassembles okay so what
was initially thought to be three
different structures in the cell
eventually it was found out that there
was a dynamic process where this patch
sort of matured over time and eventually
disappeared into the cell and what this
process is is actually endocytosis in
yeast and you're seeing different
proteins getting recruited to end acidic
vesicles as they bud from the plasma
membrane of this yeast okay so that's
just my caution and interpreting
interpreting fixed images because you
have to think about how they might be
changing in time all right so now we
have to consider a contrast
and in bright field microscopy and
bright field microscopy basically
involves a white light as your light
source and so you'd have a microscope
that has a white light source you might
have your specimen here
here's your specimen and then you'd have
some sort of detector at the end of your
system and there would be some objective
lens in between which I'm going to
ignore for now and so for a bright field
microscopy you're taking a sample and
shining it with light the light that
doesn't go through your sample will go
right through to the detector and that's
your background but some of this light
the light that's going and hitting your
sample could be absorbed or it could be
refracted and that it's the refraction
or absorbed absorption of this light
which generates the contrast for bright
field microscopy so in bright field
native structures in the cell native
structures absorb or refract light
and this is what generates the contrast
okay so the images shown up here are
bright field images of cells and in each
of these cases there's no dye there's no
fluorescent protein but you're able to
see the outline of the cell and you're
able to see even individual organelles
or structures within the cell that are
interacting with the white light and
generating contrast okay so that's one
way to generate contrast is just hope
that whatever is native in your cell
generates the contrast but there also
you can increase contrast in specimens
by adding dyes and if these dyes bind to
specific structures like a membrane then
that will increase your contrast so the
electron microscopy images that I showed
you
so for electron microscopy you generate
contrast by adding a dye that is an
electron dense dye which will bend the
electron beam and that's what allows you
to get an image from eeehm so an e/m
contrast is from an electron dense dye
such as urinal acetate or some other
type of dye now fluorescent microscopy
fluorescence microscopy as Professor
Imperiali showed you involves taking a
fluorescent molecule and attach it
attaching it to your protein of interest
so you're actually getting protein
specific contrast which is very useful
okay and the way a fluorescence
microscope works is just shown up here
where you might have a light source that
has a range of wavelengths and you can
use a filter to select one in the case
of GFP it would be blue light or 488
nanometer light and that would then be
shined onto your specimen and then the
light is absorbed by fluorophores in
your specimen some energy is lost such
that the light that's emitted from GFP
is a longer wavelength in this case
green and then you can filter again to
make sure only the green light is what
goes to the detector so this is a very
efficient way of generating contrast
because you can use filters to select
only the wavelength of light that is
emitted from your fluorescent molecule
okay any questions about that and about
my very short version of how
fluorescence microscopy works yeah
Rachel
the dichroic mirror reflects certain
wavelengths that are below a certain
wavelength and will pass wavelengths
that are above the wavelength so it'll
basically reflect the excitation light
but it will pass the the emitted light
okay and so you you there like there are
tons of these mirrors some are not
dichroic but are like what they can like
reflect for different wavelengths and
pass like all other wavelengths and so
this allows you to like image multiple
fluorophores at the same time okay the
specifics aren't as important as the
general concept of how this works okay
now I want to come back to the
resolution limit and I want to tell you
about how we can beat it
so beating we all like winning so
beating the diffraction limit and this
is going to involve a type of microscopy
that's really sort of been developed in
the past decade which is known as super
resolution microscopy so super
resolution microscopy and remember I
mentioned for you before that yes
electron microscopy can get you
nanometer resolution but you have to
kill the cell and also it's hard to get
protein specific contrast right so that
kind of sucks because as biologists
usually we're interested in how things
are like functioning to stay it to live
so wouldn't it be great if we could
somehow use light microscopy to get down
into this nanometer range so that we can
see how individual proteins are
interacting with each other and
organized at the nanometer level okay
and so in the past decade there's really
revolution that's enabled us to do light
microscopy with the resolution that gets
down to the 10 or even single nanometer
resolution and either there's a number
of different sub super resolution
techniques I'm gonna talk about just one
of them but both these techniques
basically use the same concept which is
that they enable the whoever is doing it
to identify single molecules and define
where those molecules are very precisely
and to turn fluorescent molecules on and
off so that you can select individual
molecules such that you can see them so
these are two different techniques
they're conceptually very similar I'm
gonna focus on this one here but it's
it's pretty much similar to this one up
here and I just want to point out that
one of our colleagues here at Ibrahim or
one of our colleagues here at MIT
Ibrahim sesay who's in the physics
department his lab builds these super
resolution microscope and they're using
super resolution microscopy to study the
collective behaviors of proteins in his
case during the function of gene
expression okay so this is research
that's actively being pursued at MIT so
let's just do a thought experiment again
[Music]
okay I'm drawing a single molecule or
what you would see in an image if you
are looking at a single molecule of GFP
great where is GFP here Carmen it's
right there on the board right
is it here what's that who who thinks
GFP is right here who does not think GFP
is right there you have to be thinking
one or the other
yeah Rachel okay so what rachel says is
that is probably not right here it's
probably in the middle of this thing
right and so if you're seeing a
diffraction-limited spot right you're
gonna get some sort of Gaussian of
intensity which I didn't draw well here
but it might be a little bit brighter in
the center and drop off as you go
towards the edge right so if I were to
take an image intensity profile along
the line here you'd see something that
kind of looked like a Gaussian okay and
GFP if there's a single molecule that
your image imaging should be right in
the center of this Gaussian okay and so
even though we're not seeing a spot
that's we're seeing a spot that its
width here is diffraction limited so
this width is 200 nanometers but if we
can estimate where the molecule is in
this region with nanometre precision we
could get a very accurate view of where
this fluorescent molecule is okay
so it relies on certain assumptions the
first assumption is that you're assuming
we can see single molecules of or single
fluorescent molecules so that we
visualize single fluorescent molecules
and that we can then estimate with some
amount of precision the location of the
molecule based on this diffraction
limited sort of image that we get so
then we have to estimate the location
based on the image okay and then our
resolution is basically the error in
fitting this curve okay so the error in
the fitted position is equal to the
standard deviation of this Gaussian the
standard deviation divided by the square
root of the number of photons that you
collected to get that image so the
square root of the number of photons
okay and I just told you in the
beginning of the lecture that this
standard deviation is limited by the
diffraction of lights so the standard
deviation is going to be around 200
nanometers right but if you collect a
lot of photons you can accurate
accurately figure out where the
fluorescent molecule is here if you know
that it's a single molecule okay so the
number of photons in a typical
experiment is going to be around 10 to
the fourth okay and so if you 200 not
nanometers by 10 to the fourth
you're going to have sub nanometer
resolution if you do the experiment
right
okay so you really need to see
fluorescent molecules however in order
to do this okay and the real
breakthrough came with the realization
that you could combine this type of
fitting to estimate the position of
single molecules with a certain type of
fluorescent protein where you can turn
the protein on and off stochastically
okay okay so we need one more component
which is a photoactivatable fluorescent
protein in this case the first one was
flora photoactivatable gfp or PA gfp and
PA gfp is a fluorescent protein like gfp
it's genetically encoded but when it
matures it's not fluorescent it's in a
dark State okay so when it matures it's
dark it has a dark state and it starts
out in this dark state but you can turn
it on and you can turn it on with light
so you that's where the photo activation
is because you're able to photo activate
this fluorescent molecule and it's you
can photo activate with sort of UV light
or 405 nanometers light and so that's
not normally the excitation wavelength
but if you if you shine your sample with
four or five nanometer light it will
convert some set of your molecules into
the now fluorescent state okay so this
then causes it to be fluorescent
and now it's going to be lighting up
okay and I want to thank professor cissé
because he gave me the next slide which
I think nicely shows how this technique
works so the way you can get super
resolution is you can't be looking at
all your fluorophores at once because
they're not far enough apart and they'll
all bleed together so that you get a bad
image right so this would be your
conventional diffraction-limited image
where all the four fours it's about 20
fluorophores here and you can see you
can't see individual floor fours and you
can't see what that says okay but if you
take a divide-and-conquer approach with
this if you have a photo activatable GFP
you don't need to look at them all at
once you can just look at three to start
okay so now if you only activate a small
subset and you ensure that there you're
activating it at a frequency such that
they're well resolved from each other
then you can distinguish that there are
three single molecules here you can fit
where they are and now you know where
they are with nanometre precision so you
know where those are and then you want
to look at other molecules and so you
have to get rid of these and so what you
would do is to bleach them and bleaching
is to use lights to basically damage the
floor floor and get it to no longer
fluoresce okay so this process is going
to involve an iterative photoactivation
followed by sort of measuring and
fitting
the image so that you can I'd basically
determine where each single molecule is
in your image and then ending with
bleaching to get rid of the fluorophores
you just turned on so that everything is
now dark again and then you repeat this
process iteratively to collect all of
the the single molecules that you can
okay so in this case right we just got
these three molecules we would then want
to bleach them so that we're now going
to look at different fluorescent
molecules and we'll turn on a certain
number of other fluorescent molecules
here that you see for here are two
they're a little close together but you
can see that there are two here are
another two they're close together but
you see to clear intensity Peaks and so
you can fit those four and now you have
four more molecules to make up your
image you bleach them excite or activate
five more here are five fluorescent
molecules you can fit those determine
their positions and you just do this
iteratively over and over again till you
get as many molecules as you can and at
the end you basically like add all these
images together to get the final super
resolution image okay so this is an
iterative process where the photo
activation allows you to ended to image
single molecules such that you can see
where they are with nanometre precision
and then you add them all together to
get a super resolution image here is an
example of this in practice and this is
the storm technique which doesn't
involve a photoactivatable fluorescent
protein but involves organic dyes
blinking and the concept is basically
the same and here you see a conventional
image of an axon and it's labeled with
this beta two spectra and you see beta
two spectrum is continuous and it's
staining in this axon but if you look at
the super resolution image what you see
is the beta spectrum actually has this
repeated periodic pattern along the axon
and this is a cytoskeletal element
that's basically present in rings up and
down the axons of neurons and you can
kind of think of this as like the axon
is a vacuum hose where you have these
like rigid sort of rings that are
aligned all along the axon but because
it's repeated and you have intervening
areas without much cytoskeleton you can
kind of think of it as a way for the
axon to be both rigid but also flexible
and maneuverable I just wanted to point
out that this several super resolution
techniques were sort of recognized in
the 2014 Nobel Prize in Chemistry Eric
bet sig on the left here developed the
approach using the photoactivatable GFP
that I described to you and to others
stuff on hell and w/e mourner were
awarded it for other types of super
resolution technique if you get a chance
you should go to the Nobel Prize website
and listen to Eric bet SIG's Nobel
lecture he is you know he has a very
interesting story and part of it
involved how he managed to develop this
technique and he actually developed it
in the living room of his friend um so
this is actually one of the first super
resolution microscope right you here's
the microscope and you here you see I
love this chair but you see like you
basically have this like microscope in
like this guy's living room so if you
want to hear more about this story
listen to his Nobel lecture he's a
really funny guy and you get a sense of
how science really works where that you
get this unemployed guy like building a
microscope in his friends living room
and then wins the Nobel Prize and just
one reminder to end today remember your
news brief is due this Friday November
30th if you need help on selecting a
topic please see a member of our staff
including professor Imperiali or myself
and so good luck with that
thank you I'm all set
you